all right everybody we have some huge
news today in regards to phase four of
the MCU and the future of the MCU in
general how's it going everybody it's
Warren and Thor four has been officially
confirmed to be happening and it appears
like it may be happening a lot sooner
than we thought it was now this was kind
of a big mystery moving forward after
Avengers in game wood Thor four actually
happened the way Avengers in game ended
definitely set up a Thor four slash and
as guardians of the galaxy film but of
course due to contracts nobody knew if
Chris Hemsworth was going to renew his
contract to keep on playing the role of
Thor but today thanks to the Hollywood
Reporter we have an official
confirmation that Thor four is indeed
happening and I'll break down everything
that has been said in this video real
quick if you would like a chance to win
an Iron Man helmet a Captain America
shield an Infinity Gauntlet or another
Marvel Legends item be sure to subscribe
to my channel I'm picking three winners
at four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers today The Hollywood Reporter
reported that Taika Waititi the director
of Thor Ragnarok is officially returning
to direct Thor 4 so Thor 4 is officially
happening and of course Chris Hemsworth
is expected to return to reprise his
role of Thor now given the massive
success of Thor Ragnarok this makes
perfect sense Thor Ragnarok was the best
Thor movie that we got out of the three
and Chris Hemsworth himself even said
that Thor Ragnarok recharged him in
terms of excitement to be playing the
role of Thor so it seems like Chris
Hemsworth and Taika Waititi finally
found the right groove for Thor in Thor
Ragnarok so this news comes as little to
no surprise however the date in which
Thor 4 might hit the theaters maybe a
lot sooner than everybody expected
according to The Hollywood Reporter
Taika Waititi signing on for Thor form
means that his movie with Warner
Brothers Akira is going to be pushed
back
this means that Tyco ATT is going to be
filming Thor 4 before akhira because
akira was only in the casting stage now
the release for akira was scheduled for
May 21 2021 just under two years from
now and since akira is being pushed back
this means that we could get Thor 4 in
less than two years from today and the
San Diego Comic Con Hall H panel is this
Saturday where the president of Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige will be speaking
about the
future of the MCU so it is possible that
we could be getting an announcement for
Thor for in phase four of the MCU this
Saturday
considering Thor's Ark at the end of
Avengers in game it seems like we're
going to be seeing a little bit of the
guardians of the galaxy in Thor 4 as
well which will make for a great pairing
and if we're lucky we may even see Thor
finally go against beta ray bill in the
MCU and Thor for beta ray bill is a fan
favorite that everybody has been wanting
to see in the MCU for a very long time
now and there have even been easter eggs
of vader a bell in the MCU including
info Ragnarok so if we're lucky we'll
see the two of them face off because we
know that Thor is going to be exploring
the cosmos with the guardians of the
galaxy so hopefully he runs into beta
ray bill so be sure to let me know how
excited you are that we are officially
getting Thor 4 and also be sure to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain like this video and subscribe to
my channel so you can enter my giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof